have things we want we don't get what we
want we get what we have to have
different people that have been to the
most horrific experiences life and they
found a way to still be happy because
they made the decision that life is too
short to suffer here's what I've done I
think I have the ability to influence
people because I talk about my failures
I talk about all the things that messed
me up but I show people that didn't let
it stop me and you only to stop you he's
an American businessman author and
philanthropist he served as an advisor
to leaders around the world for almost
40 years his live arena event sellout
months in advance he's Tony Robbins and
here's my take on his top ten rules of
success volume 2 rule number 2 is my
personal favorite and I'm curious to
figure out which one you guys like that
and as always guys as you're watching
the videos if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it down the comments below and put
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired as well also as you are writing
something down it's much more likely to
stick in your head to enjoy
people ask what does it take to succeed
the one answer I give them as hunger
that hunger is the greatest asset that
you'll see in everybody from Richard
Branson to Google or an apple or they
these you know giant companies you got
to become a master of your ability to
turn on your determination or your
creativity or your hunger or your
passion or whatever it is it's going to
take for you to get from where you are
to where you really want to be
intelligence is so valuable but there
are so many smart people I can't fight
the weight of a paper bag
hunger is that part of you that says I
will not stop I will not get up I will
not settle for less than I can be or do
or share or gift the number one thing
that's going to change your life the
only thing that will change your life
change your business change your money
change your relationship because you
must raise your standard I know that
sounds boring stupid basic but it's the
truth the only thing that changes our
life long term is when we raise our
standards what does that mean that
sounds so boring and dumb it means that
all of us in life have things we want we
don't get what we want we get what we
have to have memorize it earlier we all
get what we tolerate in ourselves and
other people but when you're no longer
willing to tolerate something that's
when your life changes the difference in
people is their standards period the
difference in people is their standards
period and what I mean by standards
everyone in the world has a list of
things they think they should do I
should lose weight I should work out I
should spend more time with my kids I
should work harder I should make more
calls I should I should I should I
should and then you know what people
don't do their sheds and they get mad at
themselves and they what I call [ __ ] all
over themselves they beat them so up
about it
what changes people is when you should
becomes a must when suddenly the thing
you said should happen has to happen
that's when human beings change it's
like if you want to take the island and
you're the head of the army you want to
take the iron island the most powerful
way to take the island is burn the boats
because there's no way to go back it's
amazing what happens when it's a must to
do something versus the [ __ ] that's what
makes human being succeed so you really
have to decide the most important
decision is do I want to be happy will I
commit to being happy
more important than happy sometimes
you'd be so happy to smile so much your
face hurts right you need variety am I
committed to living in a beautiful state
even when it doesn't go my way even when
it rains on my parade even when my
biggest fear shows up because I can't
control whether you're husband and wife
will live or die or get sick or leave
you or get a divorce I don't want any of
that to happen any human being I hate
suffering I do anything I can't help
people not suffer and I can't control
that you can you can there are people
have lost their arms lost their sight
there have been people that have been to
the most horrific experiences of life
and they found a way to still be happy
because they've made the decision that
life is too short to suffer I the
interview dozens and hundreds over the
years but dozens that like have impacted
my soul that made me realize I can
change this I've just gotten used to it
I bought into the theory that this this
survival software that's constantly
running and making you suffer that
that's normal
no that's what the mind will do and mind
has been around forever what I'm going
to do is something different and the way
I get out of suffering I give myself a
90 second rule it's really simple
I say look if I feel myself starting to
feel that stress filling that pissed-off
nasur upsetness or concern or worry
about my kit whatever I realize that's
not going to make it better life's too
short to suffer and then I just kind of
breathe slowly slow everything down can
I just watch the Pug albino look at that
crazy Fox everybody said crazy that's
uber said I thought I'm gonna kill that
setup try it you don't kill them because
you don't believe that thought it's the
thoughts that are stressful that you
believe that mess you up when you
question them you break the pattern
the more dentists like a muscle the more
I train myself to do it I can
authentically tell you now it takes a
lot for something to take more than 90
seconds for me now and the level of joy
surpasses all the money you could ever
have in a million years and then the
money it's easier to make money because
you're not attached you don't have the
fears you don't have the scarcity that
people have because you feel so rich
already right now I would some people
don't wait to be rich what is that
richness
it's abundance joy its happiness its
contribution it's getting out of
yourself because as long as we're
thinking about oh my god I lost
something or you did something now I
have less love less respect less money
if I think lost less or because you did
something or because I do something I'm
never going to have what I want my life
lost less than ever those three thought
patterns they're the source of all
suffering and the answer don't see it
for what it really is
no it's BS and find something to
appreciate most people who start
business very often will start two and
three four more and the reason they do
it is to the first one is in succeeding
or they don't want agents exactly right
and so what happens that person is
they're never going to be successful in
most cases unless they get lucky and you
look even bounced across something
that's easier to do but most people
always looking for that next level what
my view is is it's great to test all
these things but you got to find what is
your flagship what is it that you're
going to commit your soul to because if
you don't do that the inevitable
channels are going to come up and you're
going to then move on to something on
your essential level and so the other
thing I look at is business is about
constantly adding such massive value
doing work for others anybody else but
it's also simultaneously about your own
psychology it's your ability to go
through thresholds of control it's like
I can remember when I didn't have
$50,000 keep the doors open on my
company I had 12 employees and 11 wanted
to quit but they hated the person
running the show and $50,000 would be
like 500 million to me today and I
figured out how to get through that
threshold and once I said like all the
problems are related that we're handle I
know you
done this as well and then I you know I
have a five million dollar lawsuit was
totally unfair unjust and I finally had
a just amount of time energy I got a
bite the bullet five million was more
like never met let me have a partner who
took a company was moving a million
dollars a day I've turned into 1.5
billion in positive Avada not inching
name's Emily and he wanted me to join up
in business with some other partners not
doing the multi-level side did the
business put in ten million bucks we all
put in 10 million 40 million with that
but I find joint in several so I didn't
understand in those days what that meant
and two of my partners were supposedly
billionaires and they went broke
we bought some more companies and about
a hundred and twenty million dollars in
debt that I was on the heart for no one
else had any money and I'm the enough to
do a seminar want to throw up
the new threshold of control so you know
when you ski or snowboard and you think
you're maybe it you're just new at it
and you think you're going down a blue a
green it turns out to be a cell block
and you're like yeah and so you have two
choices one is you start to go down you
freak up you're going to die you slam on
the ground to try to hang on for dear
life or the other is they do you focus
on where you want to go ain't galley the
wave curve you find a way to cut and
once you do it a couple of times you
know like you have no more fear of that
element not my biggest one out of that
that led me to a billion I have 31
companies now to give you an idea seven
different industries as diverses like
you know stem cells to virtual reality
of exclusive to the NDA now virtually
how to give an example we do I got 1200
poised we're on three continents and we
got five billion dollars in sales
but I did that my first day another one
frickin adding exactly right so
masterful at it there is another level
the only reason you keep seeing there
isn't is you feel so exhausted about
where you are but life the universe or
God is just testing you because there is
another level if this is good giants
them to excellence Giants start good
poor to good to excellence
there's a level where all your dreams
are realized there's a level that you've
always dreamed about it is real it has
not gone away but it takes that extra
burst when you think there's nothing
left there's no way you tried everything
ten million times
and you keep going it's almost like God
is saying if you keep hitting this wall
enough times I will see that you will
not stop that you were filled with that
level of determination faith and courage
and then the door opens and you get to
that next level but most people don't
know is the next level is just two
millimeters above and it's called
outstanding ladies and gentlemen
outstanding what the god what's it
called what's it called outstanding
magnificent unstoppable extraordinary
not excellent it's a different level
it's a level where you are not one of
the best you are the best you know it's
amazing you only have to be two millions
more than everybody else and everything
you get to joy the last piece of fun in
the family the passion the economics the
freedom the spirit it's all there what
Jerry Maguire called
the quad baby all of it and it's just
two million years above and most
excellent people give up because they're
exhausted and there's some people go the
harder I hit it the more I hit it sooner
or later it's going down I'm not
stopping and when you do that enough it
pops open if you're obsessed you know
what you want you take a massive action
maybe you modeled somebody figure out
the right action so you get there
quicker and you're executing you still
need a little grace some people call it
luck you could call God but I really
believe that there's the part we do and
then there's the part that comes to us
but I do know grace shows up a lot more
when you do the first two steps on your
own and grace shows up a lot more when
you acknowledge grace in your life when
you acknowledge that I was born in a
world what I didn't have to build this
internet that I can pull out of my
pocket answer anything on earth I'm
driving on streets
I didn't pay I'm reading books I didn't
have to write that's the gift of our
lives and I think when we experience
that grace we don't just experienced
more achievement but we start to
experience more fulfillment and grace
not only affects your ability to get
there but it affects what you do and how
you leave you live once you are there it
really determines the quality of your
life because unless you live in a state
of gratitude I did an interview with Sir
John Templeton and as you know is one of
the first billionaire investors
just a brilliant man he came from
nothing and he don't eat I think with
seven and 15 play still do it the
Templeton fun I think it's seven and
fifty million dollars a year it's bigger
than the Nobel funds that he donates and
when they asked him I said what is the
secret to wealth he looked to me pause
this big smile as I've got really bright
like they always did and he said Tony
it's what you teach I said I teach a lot
of things you know it's begging he said
gratitude he said because you night only
no billionaires that are miserable and
it's because they're not grateful for
what they have and we both know people
have no money seemingly but they're so
grateful for their health for their
husbands their wife or their children
they're so grateful that god they're so
people for their life that they're rich
you know so I think I think it starts
with that gratitude it starts with that
connection to grace is simplistic as
that sounds and so it's not enough just
have your financial plan you have all
the money and be miserable
without the money then be really rich
emotionally psychologically especially
failure is part of life I mean the
difference for me though if I look at
failure is a stepping stone to success
it's a speed bump I know I'm going to
fail but it's not failure if you learn
something and so gosh I've made so many
mistakes I've screwed so many things up
but every time I do it just becomes it
becomes a way for me to explain to
someone else what it takes you know it's
like here's what I've done I think I
have the ability to influence people
because I talk about my failures I talk
about all the things that mess me up but
I show people that didn't let them stop
me and you'll need to stop you and I
think I think that's really a secret
matter and everything you touch was
successful we got to relate to people as
well oh you'll be right and also to be
total boss and everyone know it's both
and also you'd be bored silly I mean
think about it if you just said I want
this to happen I want this to happen you
know keep a little value it they don't
fight for you know it's like you see
kids sometimes in it you know your
parents will say you're not gonna value
this if you don't work for it
and you're keeping on value just give it
to me but it's true you know the things
we've worked the hardest for we value
the most so I think you know the purpose
of the goal is not getting it anyway the
purpose of goal you know is what who you
become who you becomes going to make you
happier gonna make you sad so I'm not
looking for an effortless approaches
there's no such thing so Tony wanted
critics actually that I once met said
yeah Tony's techniques they were great
for about a year and a half and then
they wore off what do you say to that
well it's real simple if you don't work
out you don't get up you don't get a
muscle right I always tell people this
is there's a daily practice like
grinding if you don't do that if you get
up and you have no discipline whatsoever
you get no value of anything if diets
don't work when you don't do the neck
sir size doesn't work when you don't do
them but most people have some
experiences that they want to shift and
once you shift those things your whole
life changes but life is constant growth
my life isn't here because I went to one
seminar one time and now my life is fit
for life I I work out I train my mind I
train my body it becomes a lifestyle
it's not just like you're depending upon
somebody else I'm not here to become
somebody's guru I'm not here to give
them a gift I'm here than to open up
their own gifts and that's really what
my work is then the only way to deal
with fear that I found in my life is a
couple ways one of those ways is to turn
it on itself and ask yourself what am I
afraid of I don't think of that I got to
be more afraid of what I'm going to miss
out on missing out on the mission this
thing on who I'm supposed to be missing
in other words if you don't get rid of
fear than use there use fear or it uses
you it's that simple
so you got to say okay what's the price
if I just stay doing this what's the
price what I need to really even get
scared and I learn all this I don't
follow through that's somebody scared
about
and then that fear will get you over
your fear and they'll push you through
turn fear in itself
second way you can do it is use what
you've probably heard me say because
I've used this in with 17 in my little
rocking-chair test right I'm gonna I'm
gonna sit myself in my rocking chair I'm
I'm 85 years old and looking back on my
life and I say I didn't do this or I did
if you find your passion you're going to
have this tremendous energy of
sustainable energy but momentum requires
you always do the next thing that keeps
the momentum going and the reason you
get yourself in a passionate place and
so that you change your life and the
only thing that changes your life is
making a decision so while you're in
this passionate state that's where you
make decisions you don't make decisions
when you like oh I don't know what do
you think all right let's decide
if you make a decision in a state
without momentum if you make a decision
from place where there's no passion you
are not going to get momentum it will
kill momentum if decide commit and
resolve some of you in the past you've
gotten momentum you've gotten passionate
you've even made a decision but a
decision is the first step
decision is like a war I got to do this
or that alright I'm going to make myself
do this but commitment is when you nail
after you've decided you commit to do
this for the long term whether it's hard
or easy doesn't matter you're doing this
it takes it from this moment and it
carries it into the future even when
things are difficult and the third state
is resolved resolved means it's done
it's like it doesn't even if you took
actually it's done inside you so it's
done out there there's no question
whatsoever then once you decide the only
way the commitment and the energy and
the momentum continues if you take
immediate massive what my friends
massive life write down in your notes
massive action is the cure-all massive
action is the cure-all if you're having
a difficult time with something your
relationship isn't where you want it to
be your finances are not where you want
to be your body's not where you want to
be your business is not where it want to
be you need to take massive action if
that doesn't work try something else but
doesn't work try something else keep
going with massive action and you will
find the way because it will give you
momentum
thank you guys so much for watching
we're continue to experiment with the
volume 2 series I hope you enjoyed it I
love to know what otoni stay here that
had the biggest impact on you and why
what are you going to immediately apply
somehow to your life for your business
please leave it down in the comments
below and I'm going to join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
chatter to D green thank you so much man
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word and making that awesome silent
tribute video on YouTube I really
appreciate your creativity and your
support so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is let's love
I'll see you soon
because you'll never earn your way to
financial fortune even people that make
just loads of money the actors the
actresses the athletes where are they 10
and 15 years later I mean 50 cent made a
hundred million dollars on vitamin water
he got a tip and he got like a two or
three hundred million dollar net worth
and he's bankrupt
he bought Mike Tyson's house twenty five
thousand square feet and Mike Tyson made
a half a billion dollars in went
bankrupt right now I don't if you saw
Johnny Depp I don't know if it's going
to happen up what the papers are saying
he may go bankrupt he made three
quarters of a billion dollars as a movie
star but he spent thirty thousand
dollars a month
unwind he must be feeling good and
secondly he took Hunter Thompson the
reporter he burned his body and paid
three million dollars to blow his ashes
into the sky in a cannon so how much
money make you can screw it up right but
if you will just decide there's a
percentage of my income that no matter
what I'm going to have it automated I'm
not going to see it it's going to go
straight to an investment account and I
don't know if it's 10 or 15 or 20 those
numbers sound gigantic the most people
even if you start with five and built
that income does not go to anybody else
and then you put that into compounding
so listen to this there's a young man
true story a theater Johnson 1950s
worked for ups never made more than
fourteen thousand dollars in annual
income in his entire life retired with
seventy million dollars and he didn't
you know he didn't inherit a dime he
gave away thirty five million while he's
alive now how is that possible because
of compound interest whenever all these
investors and say what's the biggest
mistake Americans make he said but they
all said they don't have in a compound
interest they know intellectually a
little bit what it means but they don't
do it they don't do it consistently so
what do you do if if they just means
that the profits you made go back into
the a reinvesting and it keeps growing
but it grows geometrically right and so
a friend of his came to this man to work
for UPS and said I'm gonna make you rich
we're gonna put a 20% tax on you he said
I can't give up 20% I kept in my goals
if I do that he said listen to the
government raise your taxes 20% and you
claimed you screamed you cry you
complain and you pay it and you get
adjusted to it but he said this like on
the government this is going into an
account for your future and
that compounding is what made him that
much money in the book I give you an
example of a an 18 year old boy whose
father convinces him that he should save
$300 a month out of his income she's not
a huge income that sounds like a lot but
when you automate it you forget about
it's perfect you just well he does this
from 18 years old to 27 for 8 years so
the total amount of money $300 a months
about 4,000 a year that's $28,000 total
he then puts ELISA to the market and
never adds a dime to it from 28 years
old on at 65 because the market over
those 30 years grew 10% his money has
compounded so much he has 1.8 million
dollars you don't need a lot of money be
wealthy you need time so you're saying
that even if I have student debt that
I'm struggling to pay off even if I'm
making say $1,000 a week that I should
still try to put a percentage or make it
a point to put a percentage not just
into a savings account but into an
investment into an investment account
where to put that money then we teach
you the ways to do that it's got to be
diversified yeah never put all your
money in the market I want okay